tout commence donc le 10 octobre vous
êtes au travail vous rentrez chez vous
et Lilou n'est plus là
tu sais que vous êtes des très émus
et ce soir c'est un peu notre dernier
espoir
vous rentrez donc le 10 octobre
à quel moment vous comprenez qu'elle est
plus là
tout de suite je travaille je vois les
clés et son téléphone qui est posé
sur la table je suis allé dans sa
chambre et elle n'y était plus
et je suis partie directement à la
brigade de Neuville-sur-Saône pour dire
que ma fille n'était plus là
ils ont des considéré que c'était une
vue parce que ma fille avait déjà fait
deux fugues auparavant
c'est pour ça que ça a mis un peu de
temps
à être lancé un appel à témoin sauf que
là c'est pas une simple fugue ma fille
est partie sans vêtements sans son
téléphone sans ses clés sans rien sans
carte de bus sans argent sans doudoune
sans rien
et on perd sa trace elle s'est
volatilisée
le 10 octobre vous faites quoi à ce
moment là
panique
je suis suivi par un adjudant chef moi
et ma fille nous sommes suivis par un
adulte en chef de la briquette de
neville-sur-saône je l'ai donc appelé de
suite il m'a dit d'aller directement à
la brigade pour aller voir
c'est les gendarmes et donc j'ai fait
une disparition enfin au début c'était
une fugue ils ont considéré que c'était
une fugue c'est pour ça que ça a mis du
temps en fait à
lancer tout ça mais je me bats depuis 45
jours maintenant pour dire que ma fille
n'est pas enfui et que ma fille est en
danger c'est votre histoire est
incroyable vous allez nous la raconter
tout simplement dans un instant c'est
fou vous essayez forcément de joindre
toutes ces amies toutes ces
connaissances
un café tout le monde vous avez joint
toutes ces copines donc plus vous aviez
son téléphone oui est-ce que ils ont
regardé dans ce téléphone s'il y avait
des SMS
bizarres s'il y avait des des échanges
sur WhatsApp ou sur les réseaux sociaux
la Brigade de Recherche a pris le
téléphone de ma fille et à contacter
snapchat en Amérique pour avoir le droit
de retrouver tous les snaps ils font un
boulot qui est très très bien les
enquêteurs la brigade de recherche de
Lyon est-ce qu'ils ont vu quelque chose
d'inquiétant dans le téléphone
je crois que Ludivine vous connaissez ma
nièce avait déjà fugué une première fois
alors justement et donc c'était il y a
deux ans
[Musique]
quatre jours pourquoi elle avait fait
quels étaient vos relations en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui est
cette équation mal-être alors ma lettre
c'est que ma petite femme à petite fille
oui
a été victime
d'un viol en collectivité
assez dix ans
et que la justice française est très
longue
et Dieu personnel a cru j'étais la seule
à me battre depuis
donc c'est des appels
quand elle part elle se met en danger
elle est en autodestruction totale
et quand on a retrouvé elle m'a dit
qu'elle allait arrêter
voulait rester avec moi parce qu'on a
une relation qui est très fusionnelle je
me bats pour ma fille
et au mois de juin elle est partie en
vacances avec sa mamie et ils sont venus
la chercher
des gens très malveillants sont venus la
chercher
au camping avec sa mamie et
ils sont ils l'ont amené avec elle
encore pendant cinq jours il lui en fait
beaucoup de mal
des personnes qui sont ces gens qui sont
allés la chercher des personnes très
malveillantes
ce sont pas des amis ce sont des gens
qui sont vous dites qu'elle a été
victime d'un viol collectif
autre chose et au niveau du
son les personnes qui ont commis ce
dialogue aujourd'hui
bien sûr ils ont ma fille elle les a
reconnu on a des photos on a tout
ce qui sont incarcérés ce qui sont ils
sont placés sous contrôle judiciaire et
ma fille depuis deux ans tout
psychologue psychiatre avocat police
elle n'arrête pas et eux sont
tranquillement si je peux dire ils n'ont
rien ils sont tranquillement chez eux
alors ils sont placés sous contrôle
judiciaire ils ont interdiction de
s'approcher de mon enfant alors ça
c'était il y a
à partir du 27 septembre là ma fille a
été reconnue
[Musique]
et pour vous donc elle a fait une fugue
quelque temps après
pas mal de temps après d'ailleurs
en fait la reconstitution c'était le 27
septembre et donc les 10 octobre elle
est partie
je sais pas si elle est partie de son
plein graisse je sais pas je
sais donc elle avait fugué avant ou nous
l'aviez dit 4 et 5 jours elle avait
fugué 4-5 jours vous l'avez retrouvé où
sur Lyon d'accord elle était où
elle était ouf elle était où elle
faisait quoi elle a fait quoi pendant
ces 4 5 jours
et qui ils l'ont ils ont été la chercher
dans un appartement dans lequel elle
était sur le qui était chez une amie
chez un ami c'était un appartement d'un
de personnes très malveillantes comment
elle a trouvé ces personnes excusez-moi
on veut comprendre cette affaire ce soir
si on veut avancer si on veut essayer de
vous aider vous me dites elle a fugué
une première fois pendant quatre cinq
jours vous l'avez retrouvé dans un
appartement elle était seule dans cet
appartement elle était avec combien de
personnes
majeurs deux hommes majeurs les
connaissait avant
les a connu pendant sa fugue oui
d'accord donc elle les a connu pendant
sa fugue et c'est de jeunes le recueilli
avec des coups de couteau dans les
jambes et de rouiller elle a été à
l'hôpital prise de sang elle est restée
plusieurs jours on a des éléments voilà
et donc là
une personne anonyme vous aviez fait un
avis de recherche voilà et donc la a dit
qu'elle avait qu'elle vous a dit vous
pouviez la trouver vous avez été la
chercher dans cet appartement qui a été
la chercher la police de Lyon les deux
personnes qui étaient dans cet
appartement et il n'était pas là ce à ce
moment-là si c'était présent et alors
que vous me dites qu'elle avait pris les
coups de couteau qu'elle était droguée
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont été incarcéré
en cours
ils m'ont appelé ils m'ont dit de venir
récupérer ma fille au commissariat je me
suis retrouvée on est parti la chercher
dans commissariat au commissariat et
j'ai vu ma fille comme ça j'ai décidé de
l'emmener à l'hôpital de moi-même de mon
plein gré mais est-ce que donc votre
fille ensuite a été est-ce que vous avez
essayé de l'interroger sur ce qui
s'était passé bien sûr qu'est-ce qu'elle
vous a dit elle m'a raconté beaucoup de
choses elle a été interrogée
par la police juste pour pas voilà
rentrer dans l'enquête parce que une
enquête en cours juste j'ai envie de
savoir votre fille vous a dit quoi vous
a dit je pars je fugue parce que non
elle est partie de la maison donc elle a
au départ elle fuguait toute seule oui
et là elle rencontre deux personnes
c'est ça
comment les rencontre parce que c'est ça
qu'on a envie de savoir aussi c'est dans
la rue c'est dans la rue elle rencontre
ces deux personnes
elle a 13 ans elle rencontre des
personnes dans la rue vous savez il y a
des gens qui savent très bien manipuler
les jeunes filles ou les jeunes filles
en foyer et donc elle est pourquoi elle
les suit qu'est-ce qui fait qu'elle les
suit elle est un mal-être totale elle se
dégoûte d'accord et il lui dit elle le
raconte son histoire elle leur raconte
son histoire non
elle en parle pas et d'ailleurs j'espère
qu'elle m'en veut pas d'en parler non
mais je pense que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est il faut qu'on
avance sur et que si elle si elle nous
regarde si quelqu'un l'a vu si quelqu'un
l'a reconnaît ce soir l'émission il est
21h30 en direct c'est vraiment parce que
Gaëlle Ludivine et toute la famille sont
extrêmement inquiets on les comprend
bien entendu et qui se disent on sait
que Lilou vous m'avez dit elle adoré
Touche pas à mon poste donc vous espérez
qu'elle nous regarde ce soir
on va continuer à
expliquer le récit de cette affaire
donc elle fut une première fois comme
vous m'avez dit on la retrouve dans un
appartement avec des personnes
malveillantes midi
et elle revient à la maison oui elle
reste combien de temps à la maison
la deuxième fût elle a été à l'hôpital
pendant deux semaines et demi et après
on est parti en vacances elle allait
bien
plus ou moins plus ou moins plus ou
moins donc là
Lilou bon disparaît tout à fait est-ce
que vous avez senti les jours avant ça
disparition quelque chose de bizarre
est-ce que vous l'avez senti triste
est-ce que vous l'avez senti dans les
mêmes dans les mêmes dispositions
qu'elle est dans laquelle elle était
quand elle a fait fait sa première fugue
ou pas du tout pas du tout elle était
très triste elle était enfermée dans sa
chambre elle faisait beaucoup de
cauchemars
donc là le matin de la disparition elle
va à l'école non elle est des scolarisée
parce qu'elle a peur du regard des
laissez seul à la maison j'ai été obligé
de la laisser travailler oui donc vous
allez au travail oui
elle voulait pas ce jour-là que vous
alliez au travail elle vous a dit quoi
je suis rentré à midi pour manger avec
elle elle me dit maman s'il te plaît
reste avec moi je lui ai dit que je
pouvais pas qu'il fallait que je
travaille
et j'y suis allé
vous rentrez du travail à quelle heure
19h30 et là vous vous sentez tout de
suite comme vous l'avez dit qu'il y a un
truc qui va pas tout à fait tout est
éteint dans l'appartement mon petit
garçon était chez ma maman
et j'ai compris tout de suite qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui allait pas
donc là vous appelez tout le monde et
pas de nouvelles Lilou nulle part tout à
fait est-ce que vous avez essayé de
retrouver les deux personnes chez qui
vous l'avez retrouvé la première fois la
Brigade de Recherche fait les
investigations de partout
j'ai entièrement confiance en eux et je
sais qu'il lâche rien qui vont sur
toutes les pistes et malheureusement
ça donne rien à rien pour l'instant ça
donne rien rien pas de nouvelles aucune
nouvelle rien
des personnes disent qu'ils voient un
endroit d'autres mais alors
elle a eu 13 ans elle a eu 13 ans ce
week-end oui le 19 novembre
ce jour-là ça a dû être terrible pour
vous vous êtes dit je vais peut-être
avoir un signe quelque chose ce jour-là
il y a aucun problème on comprend tout à
fait c'est
c'est dramatique on espère juste que
qu'on va avoir de ses nouvelles
je veux même pas de mal à la personne
qui leur retient je veux juste qu'on me
rende mon enfant
de tout ce que je veux vous dites que
elle est partie le 10 et la police
se saisit vraiment de la ferme neuf
jours après
c'est quoi c'est la première fugue qui
fait qu'ils sont dit c'est juste une
fugue tout à fait malheureusement
tout à fait
je sais pas je sais pas elle aurait pas
pu faire ça à son petit frère
qui vous a dit l'avoir vu ou rien du
tout rien du tout depuis le 10 octobre
vous rentrez à la maison vous ne la
voyez pas plus aucune trace
tous ces amis n'ont pas vu personne ne
l'a vu vous avez diffusé
vous avez médiatisé l'affaire plus
possible on comprend tout à fait parce
que c'est votre dernière chance et vous
comprend le désarroi d'une maman
dans une situation comme la vôtre
pas une personne même anonyme vous a dit
je l'ai vu quelque part j'ai pu
l'apercevoir peut-être le 10 le 11 non
sur les réseaux sociaux il y en a qui
disent qu'ils l'ont vu deux semaines
après dans un bar dans Lyon mais non on
transmet tout à la brigade d'accord mais
voilà des petites choses comme ça mais
qui mènent à rien qui n'aboutissent pas
à trouver
aujourd'hui donc
elle est partie de depuis 45 jours plus
de 6 semaines
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez lui dire
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez dire à
personne qui sont peut-être avec elle
actuellement c'est un une alerte ce soir
un SOS que vous lancez dans TPMP et
21h09 je vous dis on est en direct et
c'est j'ai envie de dire votre dernière
chance on a tous envie de vous aider on
a tous envie de retrouver Lilou tout à
fait
alors j'aimerais dire
aux personnes si jamais elle est avec
des personnes que je leur veux pas de
mal que je porterai pas plainte je ferai
rien que je veux juste resserrer mon
bébé une dernière fois dans mes bras
je suis une fois
que je l'aime tellement beaucoup à son
petit frère Taïs
à tout le monde toute sa famille je sais
qu'avant de
disparaître elle vous envoyez un SMS oui
il y avait quoi en substance dans ce sms
maman je suis triste c'est tout oui
c'est à quelle heure 15h18 15h18 maman
je suis triste sur snapchat
sur snap elle vous envoyez ça vous
l'avez répondu quoi on en parlera ce
soir quand je rentre du travail
et depuis plus rien
plus rien vous êtes encore avec votre
votre conjoint non vous avez de ces
nouvelles du papa oui il dit quoi cette
situation
j'ai pas envie de parler du papa
d'accord donc
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de gens qui
réagissent et qui essaient de vous aider
vous parlez de ces personnes
vous avez dit entre guillemets
malveillante
est-ce que pour vous et pour les
enquêteurs aujourd'hui ce serait la
piste privilégiée oui oui penser qu'elle
est repartie avec ces personnes
je pense oui ou alors
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes en train
de vous adresser à eux que vous sentez
quelque chose que vous sentez votre
fille est assez Christ et séquestrer
quelque part tout à fait ces personnes
qu'elle a qu'elle a croisé lors de sa
première fugue oui et vous pensez
qu'elle est retournée avec eux je pense
qu'ils sont venus là chercher oui
qui sont venus la chercher
c'est votre sentiment parce qu'elle m'a
promis elle m'a dit que c'était l'enfer
ce qu'elle avait vécu et qu'elle voulait
plus y retourner
et vous pensez qu'ils ont retrouvé sa
trace donc chez vous ils sont venus la
kidnapper
alors justement
c'est quoi ce que ça c'est une
information importante
sur les réseaux et ils étaient venus la
chercher chez son papa et que son papa
fait en sorte de la faire sortir de la
voiture
le papa
à la voiture et
et il a fait descendre enfin il a tiré
le frein à main enfin comme la détresse
d'un papa quoi normal et donc ils l'ont
laissé repartir
ils ont énormément mon ex mon
ex-conjoint ça y est une bagarre et puis
la police est venue et puis il y a eu un
ou deux hommes qui ont été arrêtés
d'accord et c'est pour ça que ce qu'on
comprend pas oui Raymond c'est
complètement fou parce que ces deux
personnes qui avaient déjà séquestré ils
viennent chez elle chez son papa pour la
reprendre une deuxième fois et une
bagarre il y a la police ils sont où ces
deux hommes encore là ils sont pas
encore en prison ils sont pas encore
arrêtés ils sont toujours dans la nature
ils s'amusent à apprendre
quand vous dites des personnes
malveillantes je vous dis sur les
réseaux il y a pas mal de choses qui
circulent moi je vous la je vous dis
tout qui disent que
elle serait aux mains de de personnes un
petit peu
Gilles on dit ils ont dit des réseaux
voilà qui est la séquestrer mais quand
on sait ça sur les réseaux pourquoi on
retrouve pas que ces personnes les
enquêteurs sont tout perquisitions
interrogatoires des recherches vous
l'avez dit ils travaillent énormément
ils n'ont pas de piste la piste retenue
c'est effectivement qu'elle serait sous
emprise tout à fait je sais pas si vous
êtes d'accord c'est ce que j'ai eu comme
retour elle serait sous emprise de
quelqu'un effectivement qu'elle aurait
déjà côtoyé et comme elle est fragile
vulnérable elle serait de nouveau sous
l'emprise de ces personnes est-ce que
c'est ce que vous pensez c'est ce que je
pense effectivement du départ c'est sûr
effectivement donc ces personnes si vous
nous rejoignez les 21h14 c'est par le
cas de Lilou qui a disparu depuis plus
de six semaines c'est une affaire
complètement incroyable elle avait fugué
une première fois et lors de sa première
fugue elle a fait la connaissance de
personnes non fréquentables
malveillantes mal intentionnée
qui la vie mise dans un appartement
pendant 4-5 jours vous avez réussi à
retrouver sa trace grâce à un témoignage
anonyme vous avez pu la récupérer
aujourd'hui
quelques semaines après
elle refugent elle repart pour vous vous
pensez qu'elle est repartie avec ces
personnes donc qui sont Gilles ou
l'entourage de ces personnes ce serait
effectivement des gens qui volent la
retenir captive pour des raisons que
l'on ignore effectivement il y a la
thèse des du réseau qui a circulé on ne
sait pas très bien mais elle serait
séquestrée quelque part sans possibilité
de communication et c'est pour ça que
les enquêteurs tentent de tout balayer
dans toute la région pour retrouver les
lieux où les gens que vous appelez
malveillants pour être ou aurait pu être
avec elle partout il cherche et pour
l'instant c'est vrai que ce qui est
saisissant c'est qu'il y a pas de
nouvelles du tout mais les enquêteurs
travaillent
les ai régulièrement au téléphone et
voilà je les remercie beaucoup de
travail aujourd'hui on est tous inquiets
on espère tout ce que Lilou nous regarde
ce soir ah oui on espère tous que
ça va bouger demain dans les prochains
jours
aujourd'hui les enquêteurs est-ce qu'ils
sont plutôt confiants sur le fait de
retrouver Lilou et ce qu'ils sont
pessimistes Gilles ils sont ibosent mais
pour tout vous dire ils sont entre
guillemets des armés alors c'est pas
pessimiste que je dis mais il se demande
pourquoi ils n'ont aucune nouvelle
aucune trace et ce qu'il se disent c'est
que comme il y a aucune trace aucune
communication de Lilou ce sont sans
doute des gens expérimentés ou qui
savent comment la retenir etc donc ils
craignent effectivement des gens sans
scrupule qui la retiendraient contre son
gré c'est ce que vous pensez aussi
madame
mais c'est ça normalement la police
devrait retrouver ces personnes ça c'est
sûr pour le moment je vous dis on peut
pas dire qu'il travaille pas et s'ils
sont il y a la fugue mais maintenant ils
mènent des des recherches des des
perquisitions tous azimuts on peut le
dire il y a énormément d'enquêteurs
pour le moment ils n'ont pas de trace
c'est ça qui est incroyable c'est
incroyable
merci on espère que ce soit ça va faire
bouger les choses tiendra au courant si
on a des appels bien entendu à la
production si on a des témoignages on
fera avancer cette histoire et on espère
que dans les prochains jours vous allez
venir nous voir pour nous dire que Lilou
vous l'avez retrouvé